on va vider celui ci
[Musique]
au collectif nommé go s'occupe de la
sensibilisation autour du déchet toxique
qui est le mégot de cigarette nous nous
occupons également de la collecte et
nous passons ensuite le relais à
l'entreprise chao mégots qui s'occupent
elles de la partie d'autres pollutions
recyclage et valorisation de la matière
première qui est le mégot de cigarette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a souhaité faire ce partenariat parce
que l'idée n'était pas simplement d'eux
de nettoyer
ou en tout cas d'empêcher la
prolifération des mégots
au sol l'idée était aussi de pouvoir
faire en sorte que ces mégots dont on
sait qu'ils ont un impact écologique
extrêmement lourds puissent devenir une
ressource
[Musique]
ça c'est tout ce qui a été extrait de la
matière qu on a inséré dans la cuve est
ce qui ressort vous concentrez ça
contient à peu près 5000 substances
toxiques en grande partie c'est de la
nicotine
[Musique]
la vocation de devenir un acteur majeur
du recyclage du mégot de cigarette en
france mais aussi sur le territoire
européen on va investir un site
industriel pour pouvoir traiter beaucoup
plus de mégots et sur toute la france et
aussi sur le territoire européen
[Musique]
à